let's jump to this next story let's get
uh let's get National with it from
timcast.com evidence implicating Hunter
Biden in 459 crimes was just sent to
every member of Congress the report was
produced following a 13-month
investigation into material found on his
laptop
the file was sent to All 535 members of
Congress October 20th and includes 140
alleged business related crimes 191 sex
related offenses and 128 drug-related
crimes according to the sun it was also
sent to District Attorneys and U.S
attorneys for the jurisdiction in which
the alleged crimes occurred
okay here's my question is anything
going to happen
I want to let's break down the crimes
you gotta let's go through all the
crimes give me some of the hot ones the
hot ones there's pictures there's a lot
of photos and videos that you could see
how about you watch them how about you
watching tonight maybe I'll do that in
my room alone how's that no I'm just I
think he's been just living the criminal
lifestyle and not all crime is I think
not all crime is evil like if there's an
evil law you have a Justice you have a a
duty to violate that illegal that
horrific law like in Nazi Germany for
instance but um you know I think he's
just been dodging it because his dad's
the VP and now the president and and
maybe he's got what's coming to him like
if he's been hurting people especially
he's been hurting himself I don't know I
I think the reason Hunter has gotten
away with so much is because uh at the
highest level the doj is effectively
politicized so uh you look at stories
like this and you wonder why why is this
guy not not getting arrested but uh
let's let's break it down to actually a
more a personal level let's just say
fine you don't talk about the Biden
family let's talk about the pregnancy
centers that were firebombed you saw
that story yes uh were any of those in
in Pennsylvania uh I don't believe so
because I know one right over here like
not that far away we actually had one of
our reporters go drive out to it uh
these people nothing now I'm not I'm not
hearing anything and that's a terrorist
attack it's terrorism and nothing but
what do we hear about these pro-lifers
so uh we you talked about Mark Houck and
how you know one Saturday three weeks
ago four weeks ago about 30 agents
showed up with 15 cars and that's on an
early morning we call that a night raid
in Afghanistan we'd help plan these Ops
where we could take down
tough armed terrorists that have killed
people and then sent in special
operators about 30 or so usually you
know earlier in the morning than seven
but uh that we we do that not
proportionally towards a pro-lifer
because he got in a shouting match with
with an opponent of his position and
apparently the guy was cussing over his
kid and so Mark pushed him in a lower
court threw the case out and now the
feds are to come in with overwhelming
Force that's obviously political I had
never dreamed in my lifetime we'd see
the Department of Justice and
potentially the FBI being politicized so
much because we have firebombing of
crisis pregnancy centers but then
nothing happens in defending their
rights but of course it's heavy-handed
abuse and we saw two priests arrested up
in New York state now as well for being
pro-life and wow and praying outside a
clinic praying praying I mean should not
be surprising my opponent Josh Shapiro
instead of fighting for our rights
during the shutdown he sued the Little
Sisters of the Poor I mean he sued nuns
who sued nuns over a religious issue
twice twice it seems like an overt
violation of the First Amendment look if
they're gonna make an argument about
like an assault or something it's like
sure but a federal case out of it I mean
that's the meme don't make a federal
case out of it that's true it was a
local protest we used to have back in
the day I mean maybe this is just a
Trope and maybe there's a reason to
complain about it but people get into
bar fights and and the cops would be
like go home guys you're wasting
everybody's time with this these days
it's you make a federal case out of it
yep and they are and that's very
chilling dude so you know what's
interesting Tim is that the Democrats
said blacklisted 21 Republicans uh a
year and a half ago two years ago and I
was number one in their hit list for
some reason they thought I was going to
derail their plans in Pennsylvania which
we will and uh they colluded with the
media this came out in the salon article
this is not conspiracy it's a fact they
admitted the DNC and dlcc Democrat
legislative Campaign Committee they
worked with the media to try to take me
down uh and it didn't work it made me
more popular actually but I think most
people though seeing Ed Harmon and tax
and people attacking your character and
your work and your your books your
dissertation your your service that it
mostly would drive people just to sit
down and shut up and that's the problem
they had with me that's why the media is
so frustrated and aggravated because I
won't shut up because Robbie and I 30
years in the Army moving around the
world to 12 years out of the country 10
12 moves
um I had a sweet job lined up I was
going to ride off in the sunset in a
comfortable retirement and I could not
do that because your generation was
getting the country for me worse off
than how I got it for my dad and that's
my motivation and they're not they're
used to politicians being a bunch of
cowards and I ain't going anywhere we're
going to win on November 8th we're going
to turn the corner on this how can I ask
you how old you are 58 58 y'all were
supposed to give us flying cars we were
yeah Jordan Here Comes George Jetson we
got one we got we got a recession in
2008 now we got economic crises but now
I can appreciate you standing up and I I
could not walk away from it and I could
have I had the sweet job making a lot
more than a senator makes but it's not
about the money I I fought for these
freedoms I defended these freedoms I
love my country you know I love it so
much that I was willing to lay down my
life for it no hero but uh it was
heartbreaking to me I struggled with
that and Robbie can tell you I was
having trouble leaving the Army I was I
got too old I reached Colonel that's as
high as I can get in my career field
there's no Generals in the field that I
work and uh I was what I just said I
said to a young man and uh at a radio
station he looked over at me and I'm in
uniform I'm about to retire and he said
well Colonel why don't you do something
about it and I was like
ouch that hurt uh I'm hearing that uh uh
your opponent's not gonna debate you he
refuses to see me on the stage why why
he's a freaking coward he's got nothing
to run on so he's hiding I mean here you
are sitting down with us you have no
idea what we're going to talk about what
stories we're going to pull up it's it's
been an hour we've had Carrie Lake on
we've had we've had a bunch of
Republicans I'll give a shout out to Jen
Pearlman a democrat in Florida who also
came on and you know it was it was great
like we disagreed a lot of things and
it's just so difficult to get
Democrats and leftist activists there's
like two that that we've had on the show
more than once uh shout out to vosh for
everybody who doesn't like them hey man
he's willing to come here and argue with
us
but they won't even debate they won't
they won't debate you I think Katie
Hobbs the same thing she's not debating
not debating in Arizona not debating in
Wisconsin not debating in Maryland right
here Dan Cox he's a good friend he's
going to be a great Governor here and
his opponent's not debating him wow you
know what I think it is honestly the
truth would hurt their campaigns yep I
agree of course that's it they need to
keep people in a in a tight space where
there is a controlled narrative and I'm
gonna I'm gonna you know I'm sorry beat
the dead horse but
they will come out and claim we've got
to reduce carbon emissions while Joe
Biden's dumping the Strategic petroleum
Reserve which is is keeping petroleum
flowing and then go and beg you know
arrivals for oil they clearly want the
oil they're just lying to you about it I
think you say something like that in
debate and they go hey wait a minute
that's why they don't want to have a
debate absolutely first thing you bring
up among a bunch of other things I mean
you can talk about the riots they want
to talk about January 6 you say okay
well 529 there were a bunch of riots
they fire bombed a guard post at the
White House these are the things that
the media doesn't want to talk about and
if the media is not advancing The
Narrative then well I'll put it this way
they don't need to enter or enter a
situation where their constituents will
hear anything outside of their
controlled narrative that's exactly it
how do you break through to regular
people then confront them
meet them on the street be like that's
what I did uh but but hey I mean what
other way then go face to face be like
hey you won't debate me let's have a
conversation right here right now let
the American people decide and I think
we need more conversations and and the
fact that we don't have conversations
we're losing our civility because of
that because when you're able to look
someone eye to eye this is the reason
why we do the show in person here
there's there's an energy there's
there's there's no uh bullcrap there's
there's no nonsense you say something I
disagree with I'm gonna call you out on
it
um but but I still respect a human being
if they come from a different
perspective and experience but when
you're not able to face somebody you're
able to vilify them a lot easier and I
and I think we're reaching a point in
this country where it's becoming very
very dangerous to how partisan everyone
is it is chilling you know so how do I
get the message out and so Facebook of
course clamped down on me back on
October 17th 2020. I I had the greatest
reach on that platform for somebody in
politics I'm not a politician but
despite that and and so because it I
can't boost posts but despite that I'm
the number one in the nation over
Democrat and everyone else on reach and
Facebook because we told people how we
circumvent it you share you share to
your pages manually share and so that so
social media is one way Robbie and I
have traveled the entire state every
single County several times meeting
people eyeball the eyeball we probably
the past couple years we probably took
100 000 hands I don't even know
and taking time we've been doing it for
two years because of all that's been
going on with covid and just people were
hopeless in Pennsylvania and so we get
invited to all these different counties
and events and things and so we went
you guys would have a great YouTube show
the few you guys co-hosting it talking
about policies and stuff I love it you
know Ruby's our secret weapon on the
campaign here I mean it's fantastic I'm
the introvert that is sacrificing and
using a microphone when I would rather
not the uh the guy down in Mexico does
this he does his daily speeches or
whatever where like what's his name
obrador I'm not super familiar but he
like or maybe maybe I don't know if he's
still there but I remember you know
being told he like comes out of the
balcony every day and talks about what's
going on and just like lays it out he's
very blunt very personable this is the
future of you know people want this they
want authenticity they want real
conversations they don't want sound
bites they don't want talking points
they just want to be like give it to me
straight I think one of the challenges
is that the new then there's there's the
left and the right but it's like a new
kind of left and right right I you know
I I grew up in Chicago very liberal now
they call me conservative and stuff
whatever but I think the difference is
you can tell me painful truths I'll hear
it and maybe I'll be like well it's a
good point man I don't know how you
solve that problem we have we have
conversations about pro-life pro-choice
and you know uh Sheamus a good friend of
ours he's a Catholic conservative very
pro-life we would have arguments and
then and then we'd laugh and tell jokes
to each other because we can get along
we can live together we're willing to
hear things we don't like or don't agree
with we're willing to argue
The Divide now is between people who
just don't want to hear it at all
there's something about politics where a
lot of it's like managing morale I think
as a politician or as a leader or
something and like if things are bad and
you come out and tell everyone hey
things are bad they might panic and then
that makes things worse so you want to
be like no everything's fine but then
that can be a lie and you're like I
don't want to lie to people but so what
do you do you just keep like a like a
positive mindset about the problems and
like this is the solution yeah I'm glad
you brought that up yeah well I was just
gonna say we we try to point people to
the fact that it doesn't have to be this
way and we try to encourage them each
one of you can do something and if we
all come together and we all we're all
gonna like you're just saying you know
we're all gonna have different
backgrounds different opinions but if we
can all agree to come together on some
issues we can make a difference and that
was that was one of the big ways of
encouraging people and to watch out for
each other right like to remember you
know
um you know
be your Neighbor's Keeper kind of thing
you know if somebody's struggling you
know help them out you know and a lot of
people came together and met during
um the pandemic they tell them about
that Fireside yeah at our rally so
we started uh Fireside Doug started a
fireside chat because people were so
confused with our shutdown in
Pennsylvania because it was so Random
how how it was happening and businesses
couldn't figure out like can I stay open
or or am I on Melissa has to close and
what's that look like and so anyway Doug
got on every night for about a half hour
and just kind of laid out the latest
here here's the list and he sometimes
was just reading through all the the
rules and talking to people and people
were asking questions hey I have a hair
salon so seriously I can't be open you
know but the abortion clinics are open
but I can't cut hair I mean you know it
was it was like people just wanted to
know like well what's going on why is
that going on and then Doug was able to
get his staff working his staff did not
turn anyone down they even got calls at
2 A.M they did not turn anyone away from
the entire State they didn't just take
care of the 33rd District they were
taking calls we and one of them was
actually talking to a lady in
Philadelphia during the time you were
talking about with all the burning and
everything she lived above a store and
she could hear him crashing and breaking
everything and nobody was answering and
she called his number got some of his
staff and she said the police won't come
what do I do and so the staff stayed on
the phone with her until it quieted down
because she was a she was fearful for
her life
and they they they're lying about what
happened with those riots it's just it's
the craziest thing to me and uh again
it's probably why they don't want to
debate why we're singing across the
board because you you talk about the
property damage the billions of dollars
that I've seen these uh um these these
talking points where they'll say oh
there's only a few neighborhoods some
viral tweet among a Democrat personality
said oh the right ones to claim that the
country was burning during major riots
but it was only a few neighborhoods it
was actually really small towns it was
it was widespread rampant and everywhere
for whatever reason you wanna you wanna
say it was because people were angry
about George Floyd or you want to say
they were angry because they were locked
up because of covet regardless Michael
Tracy journalist he went to these small
towns all over the country that people
didn't know about and he saw the same
thing boarded up Windows spray paint
please don't hurt us we support you
please leave us alone it's nightmarish
and there's there's never really been
any kind of reconciliation or apology or
admission in fact the bite
Administration
Joe Biden staffers were donating to bail
these people out that's right Kamala
Harris was fundraising to bail these
people out it's just this simple
crime freaks me out I don't want to have
to worry about it look for me
we we were swatted here I think we got
like 13 swattings you know are you
familiar with swattings for sure so we
have to deal with that you know doing a
high profile show of course we're gonna
have security concerns so naturally with
crime going up it matters a lot to me if
I'm going to go to a place and it's
already that we have security concerns I
don't want I don't want to think about
that but it's really simple on some of
the biggest issues the economy the cost
of goods and crime you've got Democrats
who have actually supported and bailed
out rioters and criminals advocated for
letting out convicted murderers and then
on on gas prices Joe Biden actually
campaigned on getting us off fossil
fuels so I I just tell people look
there's a lot of things you can complain
about culturally there's a lot of
cultural issues you want to talk about
uh pro-life versus pro-choice I hear you
but right now I know it's what's hurting
you the most and it's your gas prices
are making it harder hard enough you
can't even get to work if you can't get
to work how are you going to have a job
then because of the cost of gas going up
you can't now buy good words they're
saying I saw a report I think it was
CNBC we've got 25 days left in the in
the U.S diesel supply for I think it's
distillate Supply now that doesn't mean
we're going to run out it just means
it's the lowest it's been since 2008.
these things don't have to be this way
that's right I I understand a lot of
people may be concerned about you know
other issues in the culture War but you
can't complain about crime and gas and
then vote for Democrats it's not just
the culture War I would say it's more of
a psychological War a former KGB
Defector Yuri besmanov uh when talking
about psychological warfare subversion
and control of Western Society said
specifically quote exposure to True
information does not matter anymore a
person who is demoralized is unable to
assess true information the facts tell
nothing to him even if I shower him with
authentic proof document and pictures
and I I think that quote definitely
Rings true today with our modern society
especially with the mass amounts of kind
of hypnosis mind control that that is
really out there with some people have
have described as fifth generational
Warfare now how do we overcome that I
think it's it's it's a lot harder uh
than just just said well let's uh give
people something to live for thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there